rola fast mehr hallo mein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen zu ebay ja ich habe
endlich batterien für dieses ding
gefunden
jetzt könnte jetzt auch lesen juni
verkauft gerade viele alte klamotten die
ezb bei kleider kreise ebay
kleinanzeigen.de cetera pp und hat das
schon des öfteren chronische lustige
beschreibungen und kommentare gesehen
man hat sich ein bisschen weiter
recherchiert hat einfach gesehen dass es
sogar instagram seiten gibt die
ausschließlich jeden tag ebay fails
hochladen von daher reagieren wir heute
zusammen auf ebay fels und lustige
inserieren kommt ein aquarium für
hamster ich verkaufe meine aquarium
vorhabens damit alle dabei ist 55 euro
das ist hoch 35 cm lange 60 cm dick 30
zentimeter alles klar der ja ich würde
ein hamster aquarium gegen einen deutsch
buch tauschen wächst haben wollen hier
120 euro ja und was machst du so
beruflich ach ja meine tauben betteln um
geld liebe ich mich kontrolleur denke
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also das hier ist ja eigentlich donkey
kommen und das machen wir aber direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten ebay fell und
zwar der ist hier richtig das so extrem
witzig ganz ganz viele youtube haben
schon videos zu ebay fans gedreht ich
habe mich gar nicht selbst an die spitze
wieder so gut angelaufen buchen tv
meinig hat sogar eine komplette serie wo
er ebay fans vorstellt also schaut auf
jeden fall auch in der beschreibung vor
beide verlinkt ich dass sie möchte ich
dass er sauer als offene schule hatten
auch einige ebay fels entdeckt und
dachte sich klug an video machen machen
wir allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten ebay fällt uns war das hier
oben steht halt ikea packs türen weiß
matt so alles gut beschrieben darunter
sind dann auch die tür da war ganz unten
[Gelächter]
und ich suche eine arbeit punkt als
garten
hallo ich suche arbeit als geraten er
also ich meine wenn er sich gut um
garten kümmern kann muss er kein deutsch
können oder es ist wirklich ein garten
der arbeit
rola fast mehr in europa fast schnell
wie mercedes 150 euro wandelbar sei
verhandelbar und köln vielleicht sogar
wie wir er sieht die auch echt geil aus
kostüme harry potter oder hobbys freunde
an der stelle muss ich auch da war ein
vergleichsbild ihr einfluss war es das
hier
ron weasley von harry potter und das
hier ist ron wiese das ist ein großes
die war erfreut dass hier ein kleiner
mülheimer bitte lächeln familien
forderungen sind als wenn diese leute
das wirklich ernst meint oder als wenn
die leute das wirklich so in ebay
reinhauen man aber ich würde sagen und
waren direkt weiteren seinem auto im
abonnement mit gott fünf euro schicke
ich dir einen monat lang täglich - für
extrawünsche wie fortnight jason bourne
oder - überzüge gibt es ein euro
zuschlag für es für zehn euro
verhandelbar gibt es auch einen zuschlag
in die fresse das anzeige will audi
[Musik]
wie sie beruhigend weißer ovaler spiegel
die drei fragezeichen gps gangster buch
von die drei fragen sich da so heißt es
am trikot das hier ist ein foto von dem
hamster der seine hände hoch hebt
darunter ist 6
ich verkaufe hier meinen hamster der
sich erst vor kurzem dazu entschied
seine eigene sekte zu gründen die
wiedergeburt von christus ist hierbei
nicht ausschließen ich nehme ausserdem
keine angebote an die sich damit
beschäftigen dieser sekte beitreten zu
dürfen er steht ausschließlich nur er
verkauft diese sekten haben das nächste
finde ich eigentlich relativ süß und
zwar steht dort einmal hund streicheln
der hund freut sich gleich hund
streicheln und dieses das bild schon
sowie salz und ganz süßer und trauriger
happy hier
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich wollte ihn essen aber jetzt tut er
mir aus irgendeinem grund lag ich gebe
ihm deshalb ab schaut euch diese drachen
was mache ich hier auf meinem kanal
justus bieber t shirt in größe 38
verkaufe hier dass justin bieber t shirt
meiner tochter die sagt er jetzt nicht
mehr suite deshalb zu verkaufen ja
freilich einfach eine mutter die keine
ahnung hat von daher völlig okay
hollywoodschaukel und das bild ja die
wird jeder kaufen 56 mal so soße dip
mcdonald's burger king curry mayonnaise
ketchup barbecue grill talk es ist eine
ganz normale in serie in ebay ich habe
früher auch immer als wenn wir bei
mcdonald's waren mir extra noch vier mal
so so oder so bestellt weil ich mit
meiner schwester gern zu hause koketten
gegessen habe und die haben wir halt
gerne diese süße soße getaucht also das
angebot hätten wir safe wahrgenommen vor
allem sind sechs euro gibt es auch
eigentlich echt noch klar 74 lehre jack
daniel's flaschen zu verschenken
74-jähriger gent in flaschen zu
verschenken die flaschen sind nicht
ausgespült also für schlechte zeiten
bekommt man sicherlich den einen oder
anderen schluck dort zusammen da kenne
ich auf jeden fall einige leute die da
zu schlagen würden hier verkauft jemand
so kostüme und zwar dass bienen mein
gott biene maja kostüm
ja so war dieses eine insekt was erst in
zwei monaten durch die luft fliegen darf
einem eine schale bis das bis da ziehen
schalen zumba zumba als nächstes
verkaufte jemand seine klimmzug stange
es ist an sich eigentlich nichts
verwerflich ich bin jetzt vergeben und
mache keinen sport mehr so wie das halt
ist man wird halt einfach irgendwie faul
und verbringt mehr zeit mit dem partner
hals dann irgendwie das für andere dinge
wie fitnessstudio zu ich habe geputzt
habe das gehört weil ich glaub ich hab
da drüber gerät verkaufen abgeschnittene
fuß leber weg ich glaube eher das sind
nudeln aber wenn es abgeschnittene
fußpflege wären alter prost mahlzeit
teppich kuhfell muss da gut erhaltener
teppich an selbst ab war dass die sollen
die kuh aussehen alter so roland die
haus mit 18 18 euro bist du bescheuert
hallo leider muss ich diese anzeige
aufgeben da ich mich aus finanziellen
gründen momentan nicht warum roland
kümmern kann ich gebe ihnen nur in gute
hände weiter und würde mich freuen wenn
ich ihn später wieder zurückkaufen kann
er liebt es wenn man zweimal täglich mit
ihm circa 15 minuten spielt das ist ein
ganz komischer mensch ersatzteile xbox
one controller ich wollte die knöpfe
auswechseln und bekomme ich nicht wie
das aber soll das hätte auch eine
antwort von mir in der klausur noch nie
sein können so hey liebe dozentin kriegt
diese antwort leider nicht heraus aber
sonst bin ich eigentlich echt schlauer
als nächstes verkaufte jemand seine
netflix hamster das ist ein hamster auf
einer tastatur sitzt unten steht ich
muss mich von meinem hamster trennen
weil er serien ohne mit weil er serien
ohne mich weiter schaut wir haben die
serie zusammen angefangen und ehrt mich
betrogen
ich kann ihm nicht mehr vertrauen
abzugeben an leute ohne netflix
der netflix am stargate die milch als
nächstes bild haben wir wird in köln
verkauft also in allem eine kölner
freude als ihn borg hat auf ein
unsichtbares auto dann eher könnt euch
kostet 4500 euro 4 verkauft jemand
meerschweinchen unten steht die seiner
mini 100% vegan was kommen die leute bei
solchen ebay anzeigen an der stelle mich
das heutige video allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde ich glaube
ich habe wirklich noch nie so gelacht
wie bei diesen ebay verzweifelt das
video hier gefallen hat und die
eventuell auf bei der einen oder anderen
sache lachen musste dann würde ich mich
selber einen daumen hoch von euch freuen
schreibt mir bitte und in die kommentare
wieso was eventuell nochmal machen soll
ich will jetzt keine riesige serie
machen aber wenn man am dienstagabend
entdeckt mit über 500 ebay fail bildern
und dank so geile sachen dabei aber um
einen kanal falls sie noch nicht teil
der luke schulzeit und falls sie schon
nach unentwegt auf die glocke dann
bekommt ihr direkt eine benachrichtigung
sobald ich ein neues video hochladen
[Musik]
ein